(light upbeat music)
(keyboard keys clicking)
- There are so many ways
that you can expand your
creative and math skills
without even really realizing
that you're doing it.
Like for me, I'm a big board game fan
and I realize that there's so
many games that involve math
and learning how to solve problems.
And sometimes like, just
when you're cooking.
I love to bake.
And so I feel like I'm
constantly using like fractions
and learning how to do proportions,
just because I'm doing things that I love.
So I feel like the best way to expand
your mathematical and creative skills
are just doing what you love to do
because probably it has
some kind of math in it
and some kind of creativity.
- Try to connect what you're
learning to your real life.
It's really easy to be in the classroom
and think that it's siloed
and it's orthogonal from
the world around you.
The more we can connect what
we're learning in the classroom
to our real life, either
via sports or entertainment,
politics, news, whatever.
The connection that you make
between math and your real life
will really help you appreciate the skills
and the methods and find
ways to transfer them
outside of just the classroom alone.
(light upbeat music)